[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar tsh and thyroid function tests
why their performance matters i'm susie
valdez of labrutz and i will be your
moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labyrinths and brought to you by abbott
to learn more visit them at core
laboratory dot abbott
now we encourage you to participate
today by submitting as many questions as
you want during the presentation to do
so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have any trouble hearing or
seeing this presentation
i'd now like to welcome our speakers
first dr drazen hush director of
clinical department of nuclear medicine
and radiation at university clinical
hospital in zagreb and he's the
professor of nuclear medicine at medical
university in zagreb and president of
the croatian society of
nuclear medicine
joining him today is mr finley mckenzie
the director and consultant of clinical
scientists at uk nequest an organizer of
the uk nequest for thyroid hormones
gentlemen
welcome to both of you dr huish you may
now begin your presentation
so thank you very much for your kind
introduction
i'm really glad to join this webinar
today from the side of of a clinician
who is doing a lot of time with patients
and a lot of thyroid studies
i would like to say how much it is
important for us for in routine work
your
psch measurement in the secondary care
in hospitals
just to say a few words about
my department is department of nuclear
medicine and radiation protection at the
university of hospital center of zagreb
this is the largest nuclear medicine in
croatia and as you know in central
europe uh and german growth and italy
the thyroid diseases are very often in
the hands of the nuclear medicine
physicians the department is
established in 1959 he's 85 people stop
we do a lot of thyroid
ultrasound study period about ten
thousand modifying respiration biopsy
and we are the largest fat city center
in in croatia with about 3500
studies during the period
we are open seven days for 24 hours for
emergency imaging and for a radiation
protection
and of course we had the highest number
of thyroid patients in croatia
me as a clinician as a nuclear medicine
physician
and my colleagues we are very connected
with biochemical biochemistry labs
especially in the field of effectivity
where we are doing fdg
and we are
always looking for the tumor markers
when we have some human marker increase
we choose the different different kind
of the tests for those those patients
and we are very lucky to have in our
department also the thyroid lab
with a lot of a lot of start going
who are doing a great job every day and
many patients
of course the first the highest number
of tests we are doing by psh and there
are a lot of other other studies we are
doing for thyroid and the parathyroid
imaging
so the chemistry team is joined with a
physics b16 in one sub department
and our reliance on the laboratory is uh
really critical so we have
we have everyday morning meetings and
discuss each case
each case in in
in a details so it's very convenient
when you can you have also biochemistry
together with you in the team and you
can see what is the best choice for your
your patients
so a few words about the thyroid and
thyroid hormone status we know that we
have
aerothyroidism when the thyroid will
function normally
hypothyroidism with this
decreased function hyperthyroidism
decreased suction of the child and the
critical hormone in all palliative
performance we can we can
measure is definitely entirely similar
to the performance
and there are of course the others
including four antibodies against
against various parts of the title
clinical exam and thyroid ultrasound
what if we have if i have to change
choose one i would choose psn tsh which
should be
really really accurate
there are some daily variation in psh
and there are some variation in agenda
and also regarding fasting fasting and
not fasting
patients but since
the blood samples are usually taken in
the morning so they are not such big
variations
in the in the morning it's maybe 1.5
variation in one in one
lap
and the accurate psh measurement is the
basis for the critical decision in
patient management so what is the
clinical utility in different clinical
seconds
so we use it in diagnostical disease
in a treatment and treatment monitoring
for street and monitoring and also it's
very critical in pregnancy it's very
important to have a cure
i will show and i will share with you
some
some patient cases from my daily
practice
and we will talk a few words about
hypothyroidism hyperthyroidism thyroid
model thyroid cancer pregnancy subacute
thyroid diabetes
and postcode 19 changes in patients
immediately the thyroid
in hyperthyroidism the clinical the the
clinical is very clinic is very simple
and we have one one real medicine it's
in line with levothyroxine which is
actually the actual hormone
and the only one which is important in
follow-up of those places for already on
therapy is tsh
of course there is also some clinical
hypothyroidism and
psh's increased and the thyroid hormones
are normal and you will decide according
to the psh venue and the clinical
settings and the age of the patients
which patients will be treated or the
other way which must not be treated
what is the problem the problem is what
we can see in this day is that
some
studies and some labs
have eventually increased the sh value
in that case if this is the only one
former which is determined the further
diagnostics and expenses
are increasing
you should do antibodies or the other
hormones thyroid hormones you should
perform tighter down the sun and
trinidad and examinations
so these are the these are the moments
of hypothyroidism and you can see what
is important on the left this is a
normal thyroid function it was psh
normal fda 24 normal
subclinical hypothyroidism it's slightly
lower at the sh and the
four normal primary hypothyroidism which
is real hard
but we can't
forget and we shouldn't forget
also the central hypothyroidism or our
thyroid or sick syndrome in the very
sick patients and all the patients 20 sh
can be normal though and
rtg54 is
is low
so there are some cases i would like to
share with you
and these are first these are patients
who are already on the therapy and this
is female 73 years
more than 30 years with the state of
disease she is receiving 100 micrograms
of hydroxyl supplementation daily and
psh was always in normal range
and she hadn't symptoms of
hypothyroidism in uh even
in our ambulance
but this is interesting because this is
the same lab
and you will see they changed the method
of
measuring psh in three months
and
firstly it was
increased 6.9
and according to this measurement the
dose should be increased but there are
no any signs of metabolic
hypothyroidism so we decided you decide
not to
to increase the dose
and a lot of they changed the method of
the measurement of psh and actually tsh
was normal of course she has increased
value of thyroid antibodies because you
know it's authentic disease
disease
the second case is also female 64 also
receiving 100 level kind of
supplementation daily and tsh was for
years in the normal range no symptoms of
hypothyroidism
but he went to the
other world
you know that besides secondary uh
secondary labs we have secondary
hospital labs we have also many primary
labs with many private clubs
which are not so good control
and she had also increased the value of
ush which is 6.54
and we decide to check this value in our
lab
and tsh was actually normal it was 3.79
so she continued to take the same dose
of
thyroid thyroxine as a daily
supplementation
so there are plenty of
patients like this
again 69 years also 100 lower taxing
also increased the value in the primary
lab
but
usage measurement in our department was
completely
normal
so sometimes we also we call those words
and we said okay you have false false
high tsh when you do something
and it is very difficult because you
have they have
sometimes they have very hard contracts
with very various films that are not
able to change the method so easily and
so fast
the other
patients with the females and cellular
after lobectomy because
[Music]
and actually she again changed
change the lab
and psh was 7 for the 53
and we again rechecked this
this tsh value and obtained 28 so
completely normal ranged
tsh so she didn't start
liver terraxin
supplementation
therapy
again one patient within 46 years
old female again 100 micrograms and the
weekends 125
again increased psh
value in primary institution again
normally in our department so we
continue the same
the same therapy so there i have on my
on monday i have consulting room for
thyroid patients i have usually about 30
or 35 patients that they and usually one
two or three patients
had fastly increased value
towards which can be
diffused
again no evidence of thyroid disease
just
checking
checking the
psh value in primary institution again
7.12
and in our department it was 3.17
so beside psh then the
her primary doctor decided to check
again
thyroid hormones and antibodies and
okay she had positive opportunities on
fire global
but still she is in her retirement style
so what is about the costs and economics
in those
patients the cost of determination of
psh in my department is
is a 6.5
but if you have falsely increased psh
value
so the next steps and the next course
will
be including clinical exam and a very
often office or
pirate
we could use the course for patients
which will be more than 100
so a few words about
hyperthyroidism it's um usually argument
disease
most often more with muscle bicycles or
it can be
or it can be all sort of adenoma and
more
also normal value also increased
increase the hormone values and
decreased decreased
psh with the positive psh antibodies
suggest grains of fiber thyroidism
if tsh antibodies are not positive
negative so the other causes of
hyperthyroidism should be
so why this age and paranormals are so
important in the follow up with patients
with hyperthyroidism we have methanol
and proper prophylaxia which are good
type of chirostatic
and usually in hesitation we have
we have uh
decreased psh and increased the t4 and
we start with the
particular dose of the
the first control fcg
ft4
goes to the normal stage and psh is
still decreased so we
we decrease the goals
of the medicine and in second control
this age is going up over one
and we also decrease the girls and when
the sh is two or higher we can
finish
so it's also critical to control
therapy
in those patients
what about thyroid nodule you know that
thyroid normals today are very often
an ultrasound almost 50 percent of
patients
will present with some another one in
cairo
so it's also critical to determine tsh
value
before before further diagnostics
because if it is in decrease
you should go for the centigrade with
diffusion 99 29
okay
and if the patient is presented with
toxic avoidance there will be no need
for final aspiration perhaps
if tsh is normal or increased
the further we will go with somography
[Music]
suspicious within psychology
in a thyroid cancer we have a lot of
thyroid cancer
patients maybe two patients spend a week
in follow-up we have hundreds of
patients
and after total theradoctomy and before
thyroid rhythm with their english we
perform
ablation of thyroid agreement by using
iodine 1.1 and tsh measurement is also
critical this value should be
higher than 30
and so it means this patient is very
well prepared for the iron treatment
and first years after surgery psh must
be in a very very low
low range between 1.3 and 1 because then
we have lesser probability of carbon
cancer liquids
and we have a really really very
sensitive and readable method
to have to have such a patients in the
psh venue in so narrow narrow range
their range of lower normal value
and in patients with papillary and
follicular thyroid cancers of
well-differentiated thyroid cancer most
important to measuring forward arcane
esh
thyroglobulin and the thyroglobulin
antibodies
thyroglobulin is a human marker and if
thyroid globulin antibodies are
increased
globulin is not so accurate in for a lot
of these patients we have also must have
also very very precise
pregnancy today it's a very it's
it's a topic we are talking a lot about
and it's easier to get pregnant if the
sh is up to 2.5
million international units per liter
because and it is it is very important
that the mild development brain of
multiple thousands may be present in
children born to women who have
untreated hypothyroidism during the
pregnancy so
this hyperthyroidism very very small or
not so expressed should be detected
and
there are very important
reproducible results and non-descriptive
discrimination between
between the lots
and there are also some rules about
follow-up
of
hypothyroid pregnancies so they are by
american thyroid association veterans in
the first trimester pshf should be up to
2.5 the second the same and the third
trimester the essays should be up to
three
and the pyroxene requirement faculty
increase your pregnancy
up to 35 to 50 percent
and
should be determined tsa should be
dependent in the start of the pregnancy
honestly in all our brain women
and this is our example to show you one
thing
uh patients in the 21 week 31st report
for the pregnancy receiving 25
micrograms of levothyroxine per day
she went through one one left with very
increased psh 7.7
in our house it was 3.28
so still it is not perfect but indeed in
this case
the therapy would be increased from 25
every day so she would receive like 50
per day but in this case it's enough to
increase the dose
or or even only two days per week
and we will we will gain the
the goal of 2.5 psh
is
it's very painful and
confusing disease
and in the first stage psh is decreased
in the second stage of
the the patient
follow up psh is increased
and finally 95 percent of patients psag
in the normal so it's also very
important to have acute measurement of
psh
there is it looks like there is increase
of the patients with
these supple thyroiditis after the 419
era
and there are two very variety of the
disease there is painless variety with
significant paradoxical symptoms
more commonly shown after you recover it
from hormone cleaning and there is the
other variety which is painful
which predominantly occurs long time
recovering from
what is important to say it's important
to say that every patients with recovery
19 should be closing monitoring
for thyroid function test testing at
least six months following
the recovery of the disease
so that's all
with a photo of my staff i would like to
thank you for your attention and i'm
free if you forget you have some
questions for me thank you very much
and thank you dr
for that presentation i'd now like to
welcome mr finley mckenzie our second
presenter
hello my name is finley mckenzie and i
work at birmingham quality uk net class
which is part of university hospitals
birmingham nhs foundation trust
it's a great pleasure to be here today
to try and
tell you what's going on in the state of
play of measuring thyroid hormones in
hospital laboratories
now i've been working with the external
quality assessment of thyroid hormones
since 1987.
i've used examples from the present day
but i've also unashamedly used some very
old data to make some specific points
that might not be clear to current
laboratorians
so back in the day tsh was just becoming
good enough to be able to distinguish
between normal and low suppressed values
second generation immunoetric systems
almost exclusively at irma radioactive
systems were good enough to measure down
to about 0.1 milliunits per liter but
couldn't really tell if tsh was fully
suppressed
likewise free hormones were just
beginning to be available in routine use
and total g4 total g3 was still very
much in the majority
there were simple analog free hormones
available but uh there's much debate at
this time most notably from roger eakins
on the validity of these essays
notwithstanding that they did give good
clinical information
this is a very simple background for
those of you who may not be aware of the
eqa
eq there's another word that is used for
proficiency testing eqa is more
value-added i would imagine and wouldn't
use them as synonyms but essentially
what we've got is that the eqa
organizing center sends out specimens to
all their participants they do the
analysis return the results back to us
we do some more statistical analysis and
send out a personalized report the
laboratory can then review their data
and we can review the overall picture
and so that the loop continues
so eqa is a retrospective assessment of
quality where identical specimens are
analyzed by lots of laboratories over a
white geography over a short time frame
results from where participants are
compared to the correct answer and often
for some things the correct answer is a
difficult concept and certainly for
things like fiji for
the concept of the truth and the best
estimate the truth are a bit very a bit
variable
now eq is an is an independent
assessment of quality and is an
essential component of any accredited
laboratories government systems
and eqa which can not only assess
laboratory performance but in addition
effective eqa should assess the
performance of the in vitro diagnostic
and examination procedures the so-called
post-market surveillance so that is
looking to see how good the various kits
in use are actually performing
so here's a little bit of history i'll
go back to
the little graph on the top left there
that's showing the
the
use of the different analytes so when i
first started
back in 1987
total t4 was was still in use
and what to
draw about 150 or more more people
seemed to measure
t4 total d4 than tsh
over the years the the number of
laboratories measuring total hormones
has decreased the number of laboratories
measuring free hormones has increased
and obviously the growth in tsh has been
constant and over the over the time
period the
amino acids at the beginning were all
radioactive and again over the years
there's been a move towards
non-isotopic systems
on the right hand side we've got the
situation going from 1990 to 1994
as to what the
the test repertoires were now this is
the repertoire that a laboratory might
offer it's not exactly the same as the
testing strategy which i'll go into in a
minute but if you look there in 1990 we
had over half the laboratory still had
total t4 as part of their uh the
repertoire that they would offer their
clinical colleagues and in the uk today
we have the grand total of six
laboratories measuring total t4 and they
were done probably in specialist centers
looking at some very odd cases
so as part of the
work that i do as part of the external
quality assessment scheme we
occasionally ask participants all sorts
of things this particular example is
looking to see what a laboratory might
do
if they received a request in their
laboratory
which was from a gp a primary primary
care uh physician who sent this specimen
in with a scenario of query hypothyroid
and the question would be is what tests
would you do
now there's various theories on this and
over the years lots of people have
made categorical statements as to what's
been happening and again it was a bit of
a surprise that what we found that was
actually happening on the ground
essentially looking at the data that is
a essentially a 50-50 split
ignoring the the some of the more
esoteric approaches that people will
either do tsh only or tsh and vt4
together and that's what you would be
getting here this is looking at 280
responses from the uk and
in its local environs so that's a
reasonable number to be sure that this
is a is a representative number so this
is looking to see what was like with
hypothyroid
if we ask the same question of query
hyperthyroid
in fact the results are pretty much
identical so we've got this 50 50 split
between tsh only and tsh and 3g4
so i don't think that
when even though there are guidelines
out there the uk has read lots of
guidelines that get
we rehashed every few years or so
certainly americans have got them across
europe that are various versions but not
but it's like a question of there's no
there's never been the definitive
statement as to what what one should do
and again i think that uh
there may be a bit of a surprise that
the split was still 50 50. today with
money can consensus often the the
experts always the self-proclaimed
experts would be asserting that tsh on
its own is the way that things are going
but certainly the data that i have here
from a couple of years ago was
essentially a 50 50 split
i was also surprised but the the same
approach is being used for both query
high power and query high pro but i
assume that the the cascade or add-on
tests which differ despite the fact that
the frontline testing is the same for
both categories
so this is just a
bit of a report from one of my
distributions where we send out
three specimens to every laboratory
every month so it's essentially 11
distributions per year 33 data points
per year and this would be
an example of what we might see for tsh
we've got about 435
laboratories returned our results this
is a normal new thyroid pool it's just
human serum off the clot mixed together
and to get the volume that we require
and uh a mill or so is sent out to each
of the watershed to analyze and you can
see there that there's quite a spread of
results that it goes from about 1.3 up
to 2.2 and there are distinct method and
method differences there and
we've got in this particular example
i tend not to use specific names of
manufacturers if some slip out it's only
because it's in the public domain rather
than me saying one method is better than
another method for the purposes of this
talk but we have results that the method
means can be as low as 1.55 and as high
as say at two and so that's quite quite
a spread there
now if we ask laboratories what they do
in terms of their reference intervals
and again we've done this this is data
from 2018 we're currently doing
something for the
the association connected by chemists uh
even even as we speak the citizen and i
thought the question they are being
being devised but this is just looking
to see what laboratories did
what their reference intervals were for
gsh we'll ignore the manufacturer's name
let's just call them by the colors so
the major player in in our scheme is
that the green
uh
the green method with the the the red
method i know it's going to be read
methods
in second place there but essentially
what this is we've got 270 responses
across the x-axis and the concentration
of the y-axis and this is a whole series
of 270 lines going from the low end of
the reference range to the high end of
the reference range and the data has
been ranked from the by the from the
bottom the low end of the reference
interval so we can see here that there's
a sort of block you can see that people
will be using the manufacturers
recommended
instructions for use kit insert values
but
a very very large percentage do not do
that so i'm looking at the red one there
the bottom end it does vary quite a
little bit and the top end certainly
varies for the green one looking at it
the
at the bottom the people at the very
left of the green they seem to have the
widest reference intervals going from a
lowering low starting position to quite
a high ending position the ones in the
middle that look as if they're using the
kit insert values as i said but at the
end there you've got
some chase edges that are much much
higher
so laboratories will do they will set up
and use their own reference intervals
there's a number of ways of doing it
whether it be by trying to use
uh clinical specimens working out that
way by selecting and a cohort of
patients that are well clinically
defined that don't have antibodies that
don't have this don't know that that's a
very difficult thing to do looking at
big data trolling databases of results
that come through the system that's
probably a better way of
doing it but again no one really agrees
with the best approach
if we contrast that with the vt form
this is uh results on essentially that
the same specimen is that tsh1 and we've
got those five major methods we're in
play at this time and the overall spread
of the histogram is quite a flat topped
histogram
but any individual methods have their
own set point so this is the the five
methods just listed from left to right
in increasing concentration so the
overall spread there goes from about
9 to 18 is the sort of spread and that
essentially is the same as some people's
reference intervals so that are
definitely method specific ranges here
going on
and if we look and see what laboratories
are actually using for their reference
intervals you can see that it's a much
uh
a much wider spread of people changing
things that it wasn't on for free chief
i'm sorry for tsh so the red ones in
fact you probably guessed that that's a
habit the the ones on the left the red
ones are
probably agreeing on what the bottom
level was but at what the top level is
certainly uh changes goes through as low
as about
and 19 up to about 24 at this time point
likewise the green method they those are
people starting as low as eight noise
highs 26 the majority of them using the
kit insert of about 12 to 21 now so the
laboratories will and do choose
different reference intervals they will
not just stick with the the
manufacturer's kit inserts
and just for the completeness i'm
showing what's happening with vt3 which
is probably one of the more technically
demanding of the assays and it's one of
the
sort of bellwether uh assay for how
instruments instrumentation is
performing at times but again we should
we do have very big method related
differences there
i'm going to dwell a little bit on
thyroid function assays and whether or
not they're fit for fit for purpose i
i've done a little bit of work over the
35 years i've been doing this now i i
tend not to get too much involved with
this sort of thing there's a lot of work
happening
way back in the day when the when the uh
the sandwich assets first came out and
when
4 which is coming out there's a lot of
work there i'll come on to mention some
of that but the moment i'm looking more
at what's actually happening on the
ground not not what the theoretical
situation is but what's really happening
there so this was a paper a
colleague
jeff becker that i wrote some while ago
and it was just looking at to see
whether or not the numbers
and the reference ranges match the assay
bias and you can imagine that they did
not
so how much has changed since 87 well
bring back to what what i said before we
have these uh
the old radio amino acids competitive
assets where you had a functional
sensitivity that was only as good as
between one and two milliunits per liter
when the sandwiches come out they were
called high sensitive
tsh assays and it really did
revolutionize the the approach to the
the beta laboratories did thyroid
function testing like i think the uk was
probably at the forum this probably
because the americans
perhaps correctly were not so keen on
the three t4 assays that were out at the
time
so there's been some attempts to tie up
the nomenclature to look and see what
first second third generation essay is
these are the sort of recommendations
that we have
and again at one point there was a big
proof from the manufacturers to to say
that their assets were second generation
or third generation or whatever and we
were having people saying that were two
and a half generation very odd situation
but essentially all systems that are in
routine use now or third generation are
better but they and there are some
research assays that are even much more
sensitive than that just to reiterate
then this is the sort of
numbers we're talking about even the
other agreement's a bit off but it's
first generation second generation third
generation they're ultra sensitive or
sensitive and if you're in france i
believe it's ultra sensible
this was uh one of the
ways of looking to see if uh
tsh acid was good enough to be used
clinically as a first line test and it
was looking to see what the proportion
of laboratories that still reported a
numerical value above 0.1 million is per
liter on a sample that did definitely
contain less than that and you can see
that back in the day around about when i
was starting doing this in 87 there was
more than 20 percent of laboratories
would still be reporting new medical
values that were too high
and earlier than that when the the old
rias the first generations were talking
about almost 40 percent of laboratories
couldn't get down to these levels as
time goes on we're down to
essentially zero and i'll show later
that certainly at the moment in 2022
all of laboratory assays are good enough
and much better than this
but just look this is a bit of a
retrospective view just so that so that
you're not seduced into thinking that
was always this easy nowadays that what
you can buy by and large are very good
essays back in the day it wasn't so good
so what we've got here is
a graph on the y-axis we've got the
the concentration of tsh along the
x-axis we've got the different methods
and there are the the diff each
individual dot or or symbol and a result
for an individual laboratory i'm looking
here and i've circled in purple the
cutoffs that authorities are using so
over here there was
this uh for this method
the some laboratories were using a
cutoff of point zero five others at zero
three others at zero one different but
different systems from the same
manufacturer at the same sort of picture
some users of this method had
less than results of 0.1 yet other
people using the same system seem to be
producing numerical results of less
times at different values and
and so it goes i'll quickly show you a
quite complicated slide here so please
don't be overwhelmed by this this is
three specimens that starts off with a
strip serum
or a suppressed serum adding a little
bit more
tsh and adding a little bit more tsh and
the idea of this experiment is that
you're looking to see whether or not the
the method that you're using the results
come back in a tight cluster so i'm
looking here at the
tight cluster of results so that's what
you want to see you want to make sure
that everyone who uses that method is
getting the same same results so some of
the other some methods more of a smear
they cover quite a wide concentration
range the precision is not great so you
want to be able to make sure that the
method you're using you're in with the
tight cluster results and that you can
differentiate between relatively small
amounts of tsh whether that follow into
tsh you've added by adding in a small
proportion of your thyroid serum or
you've spiked in some international
standard or other
iso form of tsh
just for the record where we are just
recently this has been 2019's and the
last time we did something like this and
it was a hypothyroid serum and every
laboratory irrespective of which method
they used and
reported less than results i think the
highest value we got was about 0.02 or
something so all of the methodologies
are now really good and again
the laboratories that are using cutoffs
as high as that there
the systems they're using are actually
better than that and it could
have a lower uh detection limit on the
assay system
in general terms this is what the
majority of my reports to my
participants look like and this is one
for tsh
and i don't want to
get into the whole uh
whole way the statistical analysis does
but the idea would be that you'd like to
think that your assay had zero bias and
was always very consistent in that bias
so you want to be at the zero zero point
on the on a graph that's where you want
to be and these are the different
domains that
the different systems have so some
assays i've got a slight negative bias
some of it's like positive bias some
have got a low or a good consistency by
someone or less good so that's the sort
of snapshot picture
snapshot picture that we can see today
but that's what it would be like say
this is current data from may 2022
but if we were to look at the what the
trend data was for the last five years
that's what this data is each
each one of these individual data points
here is a summation in fact of the last
six months so it's a
ruling average and it's looking at a
long time period but the upshot is that
you can see that not all assays run
perfectly flat over the years
some essays
run with a negative bias but for a
period of about a year the negative bias
a negative bias is even more so than it
usually is some assets go back up and
then level out again some stay flat and
go up and that is it's important that
clinicians and laboratories know that
there is this flux in the way that uh
that methods change over time
if you look for tsh there we're looking
at the what the method bias is against
the target value i've drawn these just
up to six milliunits per liter but you
can see that some methodologies
start off with a
marked negative bias at all
concentrations but by the time you get
up to about six that's evened out others
start positively biased and even out so
there are definitely method uh
differences there
what i do want to show when we contrast
that with the trend data was that
what you might think well maybe the
trend data is because the target value
is moving about maybe because you're
using an overall consensus mean as the
target if the number of users or
different methods change that might
influence things well these type of
plots here get around that perceived
deficiency and this is looking for
example on the left i've got some abbott
data and it's showing that the abbott
data when we sent the same physical
sample on three occasions
the first two they agreed with each
other the third one was lower and that
happened with a range of different
physical pools right hand side different
scale admittedly but this is just
showing that other methods are either
flat or even slightly
go up ever so slightly so i used an
example of something going on to show
that it wasn't the material the tsh
going off or being decorated or anything
so this is real data
and you can look at this in the standard
yowden plot approach and this is looking
at
two tsh pools that went out six months
apart
and the one on the left is a essentially
you thyroid specimen with a mean of
about two the one on the right is
more at the sort of
high cut-off type levels of 10 and again
the same picture holds true so the red
the red dots that they've got
much lower on the second outing they
were in the first so this shows that
this acid did actually change and the
results on the second outing were very
different to what they were in the first
outing so it's incumbent upon the
manufacturers to make sure that their
assays remain uh robust consistent over
time
now here's an example of a method x
a particular manufacturer i won't name
it but what we've got here is looking at
the the ref the um
the lot numbers and calibrator numbers
that are in use so this dotted line
across the screen is the method mean for
method x and you can see that the the
pink
the pink results there all of the users
of that combination are lower than the
method mean
the orange one the majority of lower
than the method mean and for the grey
combination the slight majority are
above the method mean so it's important
that lots and batches
are consistent and again
it can be a bit problematic for the poor
end user now here's an example of
showing this is this is actually added
data but it's the it's the general
principle
we had
we had the potential of having 73 users
of this method we got only we only got
responses from about 20 laboratories
because it is a very difficult thing to
do it's very time consu
consuming and laborious to try and get
this information out and feed it back to
us and any data that we do get we're
very grateful for but what this shows me
that out of 19 responses there were 12
combinations of reagents and lots so i
think
i'm not saying which one's right which
one's wrong i'm just showing that there
is a large combination even within this
group and i would imagine that the
manufacturer is now one of the big uh
pushes and drivers going forward is to
try and increase the shelf life of what
they've got and to fewer to shoot fewer
lots of reagents being out in the field
at any one time
this is uh
a graph for the purists i won't dwell on
it very much only to say that
it's something we do need to
take note of that the
the international standard for tsh is a
pituitary derived material i think it
was actually
made in birmingham like what some of my
colleagues about 30 uh
more than that almost 40 years ago now
but the upshot is that
that on native endogenous specimens the
relationship between methods is fairly
constant that's not to say they don't
differ from each other in terms of bias
but the relationship's constant the
problem is that
some
tsh preparations that were thought might
be used as an as an international
standard they actually showed the same
good relationship
but they weren't used as the standard
but what we have shown is that the
second international preparation and the
third international standard it's
essentially the same material and purely
without different amounts they actually
do show a quite a difference between the
the average bias on indus endogenous
material and on this material so
although you need something as an anchor
using the current international
standards might not be as good as you as
you might think
now if you thought tsh was a bit
complicated i will i will now go into
the
signs of free free hormones now
one of the
that roger deakins i mentioned this
guy's name rodriguez he was the chap who
essentially invented the union essay he
never did get the nobel prize for it but
i think he certainly was a an
intellectual thinker and
when he mentioned things people sat up
and listened
but the what the point that roger eakins
was making and i mentioned this back in
1960 1986 because it was almost on the
back of this work that he did that i
decided to try and come to birmingham
and work with the you can acquire
service so it made a big big impact on
me personally
so what what he's saying here is that
kits are marketed on the basis of two
things they measure free t4 and the dag
gnostically useful and he's asserting
that
just because you've got one it doesn't
mean you've got the other
he was of the opinion that some of these
assay systems while they did give
diagnostically
useful information if they did not then
they could not by all sorts of
theoretical reasons measure free t4
so that's something to think about and
again i think in states we were calling
some of these vt4 index rather than 54
as an analyte that's more about measure
and if you want the charging
so this is slightly more complicated and
i
you would be apologize
with but the the upshot is that because
because the different 3t4 methods
produce different numerical results
which i showed in those five histograms
earlier we cannot use a single target
value for all of our laboratories we
have to have a target value that is
method specific so we will compare
users of an avid system against all the
other use of the navigation that type of
thing
and this the spread of results that we
get is very very tight and we are seeing
that over a six-month time window
averaging out the percentage biases from
18 different specimens you're challenged
with your your bias has to be within
plus the minus 5
that's quite a tight ask that was i
would say that
if you had a normal or high normal
perhaps 3420 if you got a result that
was one unit out is 19 that would be
this five percent out but overall it
evens out but the majority of the vast
vast majority of laboratories can can
meet this five percent limit and the
inter-quartile range the middle fifty
percent of laboratories are better than
plus a line is two point five percent so
within within individual methods things
are measured well and this diagram at
the bottom right here is showing that
for any given method
this is an abbott system the the between
abort agreement is tight and flat so
it's five percent across the
concentration rate very very good but if
you look at what the overall picture
would be for an overall consensus mean
between laboratories gets worse and it
gets worse as the concentration
increases and it's for that reason
amongst others we do not use the
consensus mean as a target value
all right this again
i i don't know i mentioned some of this
i'm not trying to do this to show off
i'm trying to show this that
laboratories now almost take it take
things that for granted uh as um
that this that this you can use the kit
as it comes take out the box put it in
your eyes and everything's fine what
this is looking at this is looking at
the effect of diluting a euthyroid
specimen
in some non-ionic buffer in this case
it's heaps buffer and the subtle reasons
why you would want to use a non-ionic
buffer but just to be completely purist
the idea would be that given that the
amount of thyroxin the amount of binding
proteins and the like does get diluted
down equally if you were to dilute a
specimen you should be able to dilute it
down in theory up to about 1 in 100
dilution but that's not including the
on-board solutions you should be able to
certainly do a one in twenty dilution
and you should get the same three t for
result your total thyroxine will change
it will drop if you dilute it your tsh
will drop but your free hormone should
stay the same when you do a dilution for
all sorts of theoretical reasons and
most of the assay systems they
just about they don't really do it they
get pushed towards the end but over the
sort of range the better than they used
to be some of the first assays drop like
a stone they did not measure free g4
the sad thing here perhaps is that one
of the equilibrium dialysis methods a
putative reference method their results
also did drop when you when you do the
dilation and the interesting thing is
and we'll come back to this in a in a
minute the absolute numerical value that
you get in the
equilibrium dialysis systems tends to be
much higher than any of the field
methods
i'll just quickly look at vt3 for
completeness this the same
the same system applies some methods
look as if they are genuinely measuring
uh three t3 their results are flat
otherwise drop up or so slightly
mentioned before that 3t3 was a
difficult assay to measure and this was
from this is ancient data now it's 15
years old but it was it was true at the
time even the big manufacturers the big
international companies could not get
assays that worked but a good example on
the left-hand side here again i
apologize you might not be familiar with
all of the
statistics we do but take it from you
that a nice tight cluster is what you
want to be so a nice tight cluster for
this system for free t3 is what this
method got given that we were comparing
people only against the user of that
method it should be relatively easy to
agree because it's a method mean we've
been compared against this method on the
right
no one agreed with each other so there
were 30 users and no they did not agree
with each other so the method mean was
pretty pointless as well so and that was
only 15 years ago
to sort of round up now i was involved a
little bit uh back in in the the sort of
2012 to 2017 looking at some thyroid
work with the ifcc now linda team points
laboratory of sheep personally and had
laboratory subsequently it's always been
big in uh 3t4 measurements so a real
expert a genuine expert in all of this
and we
looked at some work
on how we might harmonize and
standardize some of these asset systems
and again what's still going on from her
laboratory and the the current isc chair
is hubert vesper from cdc
but the upshot seems to be that
for tsh the relationship between methods
was deemed to be sufficiently close and
consistent
that with the use of a factor obtained
measuring a court of clinical specimens
you could get very good agreement
between the numerical values so with a
little bit of a tweak and a fudge you
could actually get tsh numbers that were
very very similar
and that's not to say that for all the
reasons i mentioned earlier that with
iso forms you might get different
results with standards and international
stance or whatever and there are
different iso forms out there so that's
a that is a caveat there
okay the
next analyte that the ifc commission was
working on was 3t4
now the reference method for vt4 was
essentially in two parts
the first part was separating the
boundary free and that was using an
equilibrium dialysis method that was
optimized on theoretical grounds
now the the second part was the ability
to measure this very low concentration
of thyroxine that was in solution and
that was
trying to measure things in picomole per
liter concentrations so we're doing that
by a traceable mass spec system
now unfortunately the relationship
between the methods wasn't as good and
clear cut as seen for tsh
the big practical problem was that the
values that the reference method
procedure obtained were numerically much
higher than any of the field method
amino acids currently in use
so there needs to be some sort of
compromise that would
need to be put in place because i don't
think if you insisted on using things
that were traceable numerically to the
to this reference method system you
would not have the support of the
thyroid community it may well be
something that can be used to anchor
things but i think the numbers are so
entrenched now that might be difficult
to change
so in summary and i apologize for my
very quick and fast scottish delivery
but the summary is that analytically tsh
assays have never been better but there
are still subtle differences in assay
specificities
the standardization is still against the
pituitary drive material that may or not
reflect circulating tsh
the biggest challenge for manufacturers
in the consistency of their assays
they're having a range of testing
strategies in vogue over the years
and pragmatism as much as science has
driven this
laboratories do use their own reference
ranges and there is a push to have age
and trimester specific ranges
and free t4 is a technically demanding
analyte or measurement and it will not
be easy to eliminate method differences
thank you very much
i want to thank you both for that
informative presentation and we will now
start the live q a portion of this
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's get started we already have some
great questions coming in
our first question
is for
dr hawish what do you think of
diagnostic tests from blood as the only
reliable way of diagnosing thyroid
okay
function
you very much for your question so that
they're extremely useful of course yes
we need it and i think 1995 we can solve
about about blood testing we can see if
it is autoimmune disease you can see it
is hypo or hyperthyroidism but we can't
see all of course because you know we
have
several similar causes of
hyperthyroidism for example so sometimes
we need
ultrasound and sometimes we need entire
scintigraphy we can which is very very
very powerful too for
for making difference between between
various kind of hyperthyroidism
thank you so much dr wish and what is
your opinion on the use of tsh for
screening healthy population
so we have it already in newborns we
have it in early pregnancy
i would say it would be it would be very
useful over over 50 years for example
but we need really accurate method if
the method is not accurate we will have
more problems and we will have more
expenses than we than we need so i would
say yes
thank you so much mr mckenzie this
question is from you for you what is
your point of view on laboratories
establishing their own reference
ranges for thyroid tests and others
i suppose
i'm in favor of it uh
of abortions having to do this the
question i suppose is why do they think
they can't use the kit inserts so
whether or not it's not representative
in general terms are not representative
for their
their their own population so there must
be a reason why they don't like the
suggested ones so whether or not they're
they're missing too many patients
they're getting they're they're over
referring there must be a reason why it
doesn't quite fit so to that end i think
it's it's useful to have reference
intervals certainly from
the sort of um newborn period the some
of the different ages through through
childhood and uh generally the trimester
and pregnancy and even perhaps old very
old population that you probably do need
to have particular cut-offs to use so
it's a question of
if everyone if everyone could really
pull together and get some big data out
there you might not need to actually do
this but i think that until and unless
you do that there will certainly be
method specific ones and even within
methods people will do their own thing
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming in
dr wish in your practice do you meet
pathological europe
patients they have all normal tyranny
functions so there is no any pathology
in in these principal settings but of
course people besides thyroid function
is it's important to assess morphology
of the pilot so we can do ultrasound and
we can see some models and make fighting
restoration biopsy
so we can find a lot of thyroid cancer
so it's interesting but most most
thyroid cancers that we found in
ill-thyroid patients so yes of course
besides you can find more more pathology
findings in our parliamentarians of
course
thank you so much and we have time for a
couple of more questions this one's for
you dr
from an economic perspective which is
nowadays a top priority that you also
highlighted in your presentation how
often you are facing situation when
patients need to be re-evaluated due to
non-accurate tsh test results yes
it's not only me it's also some other
cause which means this will reduce your
problem so in my consulting group if i
have a per day for example surgery or
certified patients i have two or three
patients which which in which i have to
check out what is the real tsh value so
i would say about
five or six percent percent of the
patients
will need reassessment of these things
thank you so much mr mckenzie our final
question goes to you
is standardization the way to go
i think in general terms for a whole
range of analytics was a whole load of
conditions yes so that some sort of
standardization harmonization is the way
to go i think one the point i was making
about tsh i think that's almost a done
deal now i think there should be no real
differences going forward free t4
because
it it's not really a
it's a strange beast it's three g4 and
that the different
the absolute difficulty of trying to
measure something that's in equilibrium
at 0.1 percent bound it's or it's
free rather it's it's a very difficult
thing to do so there's going to be going
to be challenges with that but we'll
i've been at it for 35 years that i've
got a few more years in me yet but
that's the whole rationale of what i do
my job is to try and get harmonization
and consistency within methods i'll try
a bit harder
gentlemen i want to thank you for your
presentation today would you like to
provide any closing remarks before we go
dr hawish i'll start with you
so the biochemistry lab is really
important in our daily work as i said
and especially in entire
thyroid diseases and i'm really happy
that we have very good very good lab in
our
department thank you very much
thank you and mr mckenzie yeah i think
sometimes the
tests there's a difference between
measuring what's there and whether or
not it's in a state of change sometimes
getting the testing interval right you
want to let the treatment settle down
you want to know
when someone started on the thyroid
treatment for example when do you do the
retesting so you can get the numerical
result correct but whether or not the
patient's in a steady state that's one
of the issues really
absolutely and i want to thank you again
both of you for your time today and for
your important research and i'd also
like to thank elaborates and our sponsor
abbott for underwriting today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank our audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
our speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time everyone take
care be safe bye
you